the goal was to create this tapestry and
integrate these worlds in a way that
really hadn't been done prior and I knew
what the comic books offered me you know
just about the character with like most
Comics there's a number of different
writers who are writing for that
character and a number of different
storylines so you're not quite sure
which one they're going to follow yeah
it wasn't a whole lot about where the
character was going to end up it was
more about you know the burden of trying
to create this universe but that didn't
really fall in my lap that was other
people's responsibility and we had
Downey driving the you know what I
mean like he had already done so well
with Iron Man and it was such a
phenomenon that you you kind of felt
like okay this is we're off on the right
foot